yeah I had that [ __ ] voice dude who
[ __ ] no that was a talk [ __ ] you know
when you talk [ __ ] you cry you don't
[ __ ] do it
whatever dude
[Music]
tough news in North Carolina a child has
been found locked in a dog kennel and
has told detectives that he's been
living outside since April
this is North Carolina is it familiar
with weather in North Carolina it's hot
it's pretty hot [ __ ] white dude
because I tell you I'll tell you what
what the song [ __ ] do
that's not the question we're asking
what the song [ __ ] do
sounds like a bad kid dude it sounds
like a bad kid all right something
[ __ ] up that's right he let the cabs
out again if the cows are out I swear to
God that song [ __ ] has another week
the cows are always out don't you
[ __ ] release the goddamn case I used
to live in North Carolina did you really
yeah dude and uh Bojangles oh Jangles
that's right and now I lived in a uh
Greensboro and then Smithfield a little
small town do you like it over there
yeah I used to I was working in the
fields and [ __ ] like the vices really
what kind of work the [ __ ] uh really
grapes do you see any kids in uh kennels
no all the [ __ ] time what does some
[ __ ] do well did you see any bunch of
cows out yeah they got a bunch of cows
out dude so uh yeah he uh told deputies
he's been living in the kennel since
April and that he didn't have a room in
the Davidson County house where his
father and stepmother were living on
October 19th Davidson County deputies
responded to a home in Lexington about
reports oh nice nine-year-old boy locked
in a dog kennel they responded to the
home on Crest Road Road and found the
child he was taken to the hospital and
his father's stepmother and Stepmother's
Aunt who owns a property were arrested
and charged with felony child abuse what
if he was like pretending to be a dog
and then he locked himself in there nine
out of 10 cases of the kids are
pretending to be dogs right I mean
you know
his imagination and we're gonna like get
him out of that
was America sorry I had a Elementary
School principal that would have her son
sleep out in the doghouse really yeah
for fun though or no as punishment yeah
because like I guess he got like a B on
something and she was like you're
sleeping on the doghouse watch it's like
a nice ass dog house that's what I was
gonna say it's one of those like
two-story Dog House nah she was being
mean about it because then she'll like
scoop up poop and put in his backpack
that sounds pretty hardcore wait what
hold on let's talk about this that's a
teacher this is like him
and [ __ ] I talked to her once too she
was nice [ __ ] 90s huh she told you
guys about this no it was on the news
articles yeah she put poop in his
backpack yeah that's hard why are you
laughing you insensitive something
because that's kind of funny dude that's
why it's [ __ ] up it's like Ryan's wild
but you know sounds like a bad kid one
time because it was raining and I didn't
want my dog to be alone so I guess my
parents freaked out because I didn't
tell them and they're like where the
[ __ ] is he it's raining is he outside
and then they saw the dog come out and
then me outside and we're all muddied
together
she was so pissed but I was like I
didn't understand why gay you know okay
I'm joking
so search words
search words
baby yeah everybody's gay what does it
yeah yeah uh search warrants showed that
an anonymous person called 9-1-1 just
before 7 A.M on October 19th who told
them about the child and said that her
husband had taken the child some food in
the past so they were like low-key
feeding this kid in the past they should
have called the cops sooner I mean
they're not animals they fed the kid
yeah yeah exactly yeah he's the animal
the child was found and he's gay and the
child no he's not no he's not gay come
on hey hey no he's not no he's just fact
checking everybody here if he was he'll
like doggy style okay that's enough that
is enough hey maybe we gotta pause real
quick oh
oh that is enough oh yeah all right dude
turn the video off the child was found
in a t-shirt
Corner Camp child was found in the
T-shirt jeans and with no shoes on a
night when temperatures reached below
freezing deputies over uh observed frost
on the ground when they arrived and they
broke into the padlock kennel to get the
child for his safety that's [ __ ] up
the deputies saw a woman at the back
door of the home holding a small child
she walked out of sight and turned the
lights off according to warrants so
imagine just being [ __ ] like you're
like what's that racket outside [ __ ]
deputies there just knocking this you
know breaking this kid away from this
Kettle and you're like oh yeah scooting
back in so she turns off the lights she
tries to hide obviously they found her
by turning on the lights
Gunther
oh [ __ ] the deputy is secure I mean
Gunter looks like he was stay outside
yeah dude God they're just chilling out
Deputy secured the nine-year-old and
then forced to entry into the home where
they detained Sarah Starr the little
boy's stepmother she told deputies she
did not know the combination to the lock
on the kennel and that only her Aunt
Shelly Barnes knew it that's what it was
she's free to go anything else they're
lazy they don't know how to do no we
didn't know and their Hillbillies it was
actually well I'll be honest I don't
know what the goddamn number could code
and that's what they said they felt bad
about it they were like we did feel bad
it was but it was the ant they were
basically trying to shift thankfully
they thought dude long story short uh
kids were obviously taken into social
services and everybody else and locked
up like like they're not gonna come out
and create [ __ ] crimes because of
this like
doesn't do [ __ ] that isn't that is a
scary dark outcome right it's like yeah
he's gonna be safe for taking the social
services and now they're really [ __ ]
now they're really [ __ ] now they're like
they're like [ __ ] yeah started
robbing and [ __ ] putting people in
candles and [ __ ] like why am I doing
this yeah find his own [ __ ] kid
that's gonna be next dude well
um
that's what happens though right right
if the kids get abused like this it just
it ends up being a psychic here's the
thing
you got abused the right way you know
what I'm saying it's like no you know
like healthy abuse learn some [ __ ] from
like round people you know do the normal
spanking go in your room and just shut
the [ __ ] up for a little bit Yeah that's
the Noise Okay the kid will get it right
you don't gotta lock them up in a kennel
look at she's going back to her trauma
and [ __ ] like this looks like oh [ __ ]
look at this is good she just went in
the place right now she's just [ __ ]
took off to her childhood but you know
what I mean like how our parents used to
do it the normal [ __ ] ass whooping a
couple threats making his [ __ ] you
know the knife in the face for a second
you're like all right yeah really
destroy our character what was the worst
worst discipline that your parents ever
inflicted on you dude [ __ ] it I remember
they threw a rock at me oh but you
didn't wash them though yeah
they just threw it at you yeah
it's like I hit with a rock and then by
the time I like realized it was a rock
he caught up to me and he [ __ ] hit me
and kicked me and did all that and that
was like five months ago
technically technically
I was out of line I was out of line you
know what I mean I it was I was before I
know it I was like oh I am under his
roof God damn it he's right I [ __ ] up
sorry Pop I forgot the rules you know
what I mean under his roof it's been a
while yeah you forget like ah
are you a middle child yeah I'm a middle
child yeah your older sibling is a
brother no my older is a is a girl and
then my younger two younger brothers are
boys did the did your older sister get
disciplined in similar fashion um she
was a girl latina girls don't really get
disciplined like that they just like get
yelled at and then they sent to their
room let's be nice they really don't
beat the [ __ ] out of the boys they beat
the [ __ ] right there used to [ __ ]
sometimes I feel like it wasn't really a
spanking it was more like
wait a minute
[Laughter]
the door
oh my God [ __ ] got it dude
so out of out of your brothers who got
beat up the most me you're looking the
original I can see why
if you're talking [ __ ] to your pops or
what yeah I was a bad [ __ ] kid I was
a kid that you told him like I'll do
this hey Don it's gonna break
you test them huh I didn't do it
I didn't do it
I heard it
I got something oh my God it was here
they leave
oh my daughter I didn't do it
you know that was you you deserve that
you [ __ ] did that's right
yeah
or something like that yeah dude but I
was showing up at the house he's
aggressive not even knowing I'm doing
something bad I'll just be like yeah
okay he's doing something like that
they're like God put it down and I'm
like why because you can't be playing
with it why not and I just don't just
don't [ __ ] touch it yeah yeah
I'm not touching it
I'm not touching it
oh my God and everyone's about to go
around here once in a while you
accidentally do touch it I'm not
touching I'm not ready to do it
I love the height difference the height
I had that [ __ ] voice dude who
[ __ ] no that was a talk [ __ ] you know
when you talk [ __ ] you cry you don't
[ __ ] doing whatever
but you're talking [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
idiot oh you're a [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] stupid dude you were trying to
say but you can so you just make a noise
oh my God
whatever get the [ __ ] out of here
it's so fresh in your memory yeah last
week all I got is that you yell at my
dad like okay already that's all you had
oh that's me feeling that's me feeling
tough and [ __ ] whatever
[Music]
[Music]